[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la plus belle aventure et le plus beau
voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ratez vous voulez
c'est tellement heureux de vous recevoir
quand j'ai demandé ça un bémol et qui
venait et qui m'ont dit oui mais
franchement
tu as la capitale sympathie et tu
chantes très très bien on t'a entendu
chanter une voix incroyable soit tu
danses très très bien tu chantes bien il
se trouve en plus on t'a ça pour toi tu
es beau bon ben tu peux rien faire j'ai
connu ça aussi c'est un truc qu'on doit
traîner c'est un truc qu'on a traîner on
doit traîner comment allez-vous
trop content d'être en vrai moi je suis
quelqu'un que je regarde beaucoup TPMP
et tout trop content d'être sur le
plateau elle est cassé et surtout amis
franchement ça fait trop plaisir de les
revoir bébé on arrête la lampe de bois
tu es sorti la semaine dernière tu
partais pour cette semaine pour être
vainqueur est-ce que franchement quand
on sort un petit peu comme ça taux d'une
aventure comment on le vit est-ce qu'il
y a une blessure narcissique est-ce que
c'est comment on vit ça est-ce qu'on
rentre chez soi on pleure est-ce qu'on
est triste c'était quand même un projet
de vie quand même non alors franchement
c'était moi j'en ai retenu vraiment que
du kif c'était très fatigant parce que
c'est notre première télé à tous c'est
quelque chose qu'on pas du tout
l'habitude et même c'est que je trouve
que le niveau était tellement haut qu'on
a aussi une pression deux semaines en
semaine qui monte mais vraiment c'était
enfin moi j'en ai retenu que 10 kifs
même de sortir aussi de ça finalement ça
fait aussi du bien quand on dans son
cocon on retrouve un peu les gens qu'on
connaît son ouais en fait à scène par
exemple oui tu as été sauvé une première
fois toi donc tu dis ça peut être sauvé
une deuxième fois tu dis est-ce que tu
t'es pas moi j'entre chez moi oui je
pense que ma famille me réconcilie enfin
je pleure c'est dur quand même c'est
c'est tu crois quand il va au début mais
franchement déjà pour moi j'étais hyper
heureux d'être parmi les 13 premiers
parce qu'il y a quand même 20 000
candidatures et c'est oufissime faut pas
enfin c'est une expérience énorme et
c'est un rêve d'enfant pour nous parce
que on a pas réellement connu la Star
Academy on a toujours entendu mais le
rêve il veut pas s'arrêter à bout de
deux semaines à Seine oui c'est vrai
mais après on a quand même enfin moi
personnellement je garde que le positif
des choses et c'est que le début d'une
aventure donc voilà ça veut dire que
vous avez début d'aventure il y a déjà
des gens qui vous ont contacté pour
signer pour faire des choses alors nous
on a aucun accès au téléphone donc nous
on a attends
on est au courant
pour l'instant pas grand chose je vous
avoue que là on sort à peine du truc
donc on
rentre chez nous tranquillement et tout
déjà en je voudrais juste remercier
parce que on a reçu tellement de
messages de gens qui nous ont soutenu et
que finalement ça c'est juste important
et que nous on n'a pas du tout habitué à
ça moi alors moi clairement sur le truc
j'ai donné mon maximum que je pouvais
c'est juste que j'étais malade pendant
pratiquement beaucoup le moment de
l'aventure surtout les débuts des Vals
et j'ai fait avec c'est juste que moi je
prends sur moi je suis pas du genre à
dire quoi que ce soit du coup j'ai fait
mon maximum en tout cas sur YouTube à
Paris qui fait tout ça ou tu vas
repartir à Tahiti revoir ta famille et
merci au revoir alors moi faut savoir
déjà ça fait 4 ans que je suis en France
et du coup ça fait cinq mois que
vraiment j'habite à Paris et justement
pour bosser sur moi je suis dans quel
coin Paris toi
15e ça va le 15e c'est gros du coup je
pense je peux le dire
je connais bien je connais bien
[Rires]
absolument franchement c'est vous dire
alors on va regarder quelques petits
moments parce que forcément on va
regarder le Mac compil Hassen oula non
mais non tu es non seulement extrêmement
sympathique mais tu chantes très belle
façon ça c'est un truc dont on va parler
bouché trop bien on voulait du genre
Pascal nous on veut des on veut des
casseroles tu vois ce que je veux dire
et malheureusement on a ça
quelqu'un de très solaire qui adore
sourire qui adore rigoler
[Musique]
on a tous vu des efforts mais encore un
peu trop de la thune
vous bossez vous passez pas vous passez
machin
[Applaudissements]
et puis il y a pas eu d'engueulade de
clan qui se forment comme toujours il y
a rien de tout ça vous êtes sage en fait
c'est hyper
impressionnant parce que il y a toujours
ce côté hyper bienveillant les uns des
autres on est toujours là à centrer etc
et c'est on est hyper soudé on se
connaît pas tous
mon grand-père
moi je suis dit ça comme ça le sinon il
voulait ma place
surtout je trouve il y a pas de cassos
de la chanson il y a pas de George Alain
Jean-Pascal qui s'appelle chanter une
note juste là qu'on voit Camille ça a
été la première éliminée alors qu'elle a
le niveau de The Voice
rien mais ils ont pas été pris pour
faire de la télé-réalité pour
s'engueuler pour des mecs ou quoi que ce
soit comme dans les anges ils ont été
pris pour leur talents et pour devenir
des artistes Académie et c'est pas de la
téléréalité si tu veux bien sûr du coup
il y a une petite histoire d'amour
spectateur serait très content alors en
même temps puisqu'on parlait d'amis qui
a chanté tout à l'heure mais on a aussi
la compil
[Musique]
la famille
ok 50 secondes les amis les amis
champion
mais vous savez quand vous entend juste
que vous sachiez à la sonnerie j'ai
lancé le chrono et on est à 3,45 et on
va dire par séquence de 10 secondes
c'est un burpees OK
en vrai
dites-nous la vérité en vrai le parce
que vous êtes supposé être complètement
en dehors au téléphone on vous donnait
des infos un peu c'est bien ce que tu
fais tu es dans le top 3 les gens
t'adorent dehors vos familles vous
disent dans ma famille ils étaient 7 à
parler en même temps
parce que non ils savent que ils sont
entendus donc on a pas le droit en fait
d'avoir de contact
extérieures sont venus vous avez vu
Jean-Pascal Mario tout ça ils sont venus
et qu'il y a eu beaucoup de coups vous
le voyez pas mais nous sur TF1 max il y
a eu beaucoup de coupes parce qu'ils
vont donner des informations c'est vrai
c'est ou pas moi je vous avoue que j'ai
pas du tout regardé
et vous en parler ben non on n'est pas
du tout au courant en fait de ce qui est
pris ou gavé par la mais quand les
anciens sont venus et qui vous ont parlé
à vous est-ce qui vous ont donné des des
informations sur dehors sur ce qui se
passe
personnellement non mais j'avoue que en
fait c'était tellement un grand banquier
et en parler tout ça en même temps parce
que on était que c'est un peu l'an la
génération la nouvelle génération du
coup ils avaient tellement d'anecdotes à
nous raconter mais voilà ça sentait pas
forcément de ça qui est très honnête et
qui est pas du tout méchant mais c'est
ça aussi mieux du showbizk quand vous
voyez tous les anciens qui arrivent et
que vous vous dites ils ont été 16 à peu
près sur 10 saisons sans fait 160 il y
en a on va dire honnêtement six qu'on
fait une carrière sur 160 et c'est ça le
met du showbiz comme vous les voyez et
tout ça est-ce que vous vous disiez ça
va être dur quand même voilà ce que je
fais ce métier ça va être très dur mais
après c'est le monde de la musique et on
sait dans quoi on plonge en fait donc on
sait que du jour au lendemain il peut se
passer quelque chose comme rien du tout
mais ça nous de prouver de se battre
pour pouvoir réussir entre autres et
prouver qui on est réellement
artistiquement parlant après aujourd'hui
avec l'évolution des réseaux sociaux
c'est plus du tout la même dynamique
tout peut prendre un tournant du jour au
lendemain est-ce que vous dit dans la
rue parce que là maintenant vous sortez
dans la rue tout ça vous êtes retourné
chez vous toi dans le 15e j'adore ce
quartier qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit dans
la rue les gens vous arrêtent vous
reconnaissent tout de suite ou pas du
tout à totalement ça vous dit
franchement ça dépend de on est mais oui
si c'est un clac ou une boulangerie mais
c'est hallucin genre les gens comment
ils nous parlent comme si en fait
finalement ils nous connaissait parce
que je pense que on était tous les soirs
avec eux dans leur salon et en même
temps c'est un impressionnant genre tout
l'amour qu'on reçoit des gens et on
n'est pas forcément préparé à ça parce
que les protège ta copine parce que sur
Instagram fais voir des trucs non
franchement ça va franchement ça va bien
pour le coup par exemple ma copine a
fait passer aussi de l'aventure ou moi
j'ai regardé quelques trucs non mais les
minutes d'appels qu'on aille avec nous
c'était
faut se dire quand même c'est quand même
assez dur c'est c'est une rigueur qu'on
a aussi dans le travail tous les jours
qu'on met en tout cas personnellement
j'avais pas avant et que du coup les
moments on retrouve nos proches comme ça
alors j'ai laissé par les chroniqueurs
et après j'ai une question pour vous
elle est dure mais s'il y a pas de
réponse tant pis pour vous parce que
peut-être il y aurait des possibilités
de chroniques plus tard je vends rien
mais il faut que j'ai des réponses qui
veut parler en tant que téléspectateur
j'ai l'impression que la sensation que
j'ai c'est que il y a un petit peu de
favoritisme peut-être pour certains
candidats l'impression que il y a des
coachs qui préfèrent par exemple quand
je vois Yanis Marshall qui aime beaucoup
Carla je me dis dans les votes dans tout
ça comment ça se passe est-ce que vous
vous pensez est-ce que votre point de
vue c'est que potentiellement il y a des
élèves qui sont plus mis en avant que la
réponse pour homme et je te promets
qu'il y en a pas hein je peux me poser
la question est-ce que tu peux vraiment
poser la question un peu la preuve je te
promets ça comment en fait la question
c'est clairement est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a des favoris dans l'émission
alors franchement moi je pense pas du
tout mais c'est juste que chacun je
pense à ses affinités que ça soit des
professionnels que ça soit entre nous
mais franchement ça met en fait c'est
tellement je vous jure que le programme
était tellement bienveillant que ça soit
dans les jurys est-ce que pour vous ils
ont gagné au naturel là comme ça il y a
comme ça je parle pas des juges mais
est-ce que pour vous il y a un gagnant
naturel si tu devais me demander voilà
pour toi qui va gagner franchement j'ai
pas d'amis parce que c'est les c'est
l'évolution je ne sais pas il faut que
je regarde non je veux un avis
alors moi je pense que c'est l'heure toi
non moi moi je dirais que par rapport au
mérite au travail etc je dirais Enola
alors moi je dirais que celle que je
vais régler la Star Academy je pense
c'est à nicha mais si je devais dire
plutôt la personne que j'aimerais vous
gagner je pense ça serait plus un erreur
ça serait genre Chris parce que c'est
énormément touché dans le truc bien sûr
en revanche j'ai une question pour
Hassen alors
aidez-nous quand on a dit qu'il y aurait
Keen'V et Zaz tu as pris un fou rire
pourquoi parce que tu les connaissais
pas est-ce que ça te semblait d'un autre
temps parce que pas du tout en fait il
faut savoir enfin sur mon portrait
normalement ça a été dit je suis
animateur donc animateur pour les
enfants colo etc et Keen'v En fait c'est
toutes ces chansons c'est les musiques
que je faisais pour les mini disco avec
les enfants et cetera du coup d'un coup
je vais un flashback de plein de
souvenirs mais vraiment plein plein de
souvenirs et du coup j'ai exposé du coup
j'ai mal à la Régie est-ce que si en
régie ils ont encore ce magnéto qu'on
avait passé la semaine dernière quand on
vous annonce le nom des gens qui
viennent ah non on me dit qu'on l'a pas
bon on est désolé on voit la tête de
Senzo il y aura un machin
et c'est quand l'inconnu et alors
justement on va parler de Senzo parce
qu'il y a aussi toi la scenzo ont appelé
le Justin Bieber du château tu danses un
truc de malade mental hip-hop et tout ça
et c'est un petit peu ce qui a été dit
peut-être un peu sur toi au début c'est
finalement tu danses très très bien et
c'est un peu ce qui est éclipsé
finalement la partie la partie chanson
regarde
du coup moi c'est Enzo
j'ai envie de t'emmener Justin Bieber en
France même si bon ça aide du travail
d'apprendre à chanter danser en même
temps
[Musique]
a fait beaucoup d'efforts cette semaine
comment tu te sens qu'est-ce qui te fait
cette émotion
moi je me suis carrément éclaté sur
scène mais je sais que la voix c'était
pas sage
et le pont de chaton il a même pas de
famille à Paris heureusement qu'il y a
Mathieu qui est là comme pour l'autre
et ben maintenant tu as un ami qui est
là sache-le alors Tendo tu danses très
bien et tu lances tellement bien Senzo
que pour vous amuser un peu au début tu
as lancé un groupe qui s'appelle les
deux les Toucy S avec tes potes qui est
un peu une sorte de base-bandes mais tu
sais que les boys bandes ça revient
énormément en ce moment notamment en
Angleterre et aux États-Unis et un boys
band avec des bombes comme vous qui
savez danser parce que vous dansez vous
chantez mieux pardon que les anciens
boys band qui savaient pas chanter et
vous dansez très bien ça c'est un truc
qui pourrait voir le jour ou pas c'est
un producteur alors franchement je sais
pas tout ce qui serait musique en tout
cas tout ce que je sais c'est que Stan
et Chris clairement je les revends en
dehors de l'aventure et pas que c'est en
vrai on a tellement passé une bonne
aventure ensemble mais après côté boys
band et tout même nous on en a parlé
entre nous c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui nous intéresserait
professionnellement mais juste c'est un
délire entre nous entre potes mais vous
êtes plus précis parce que je me sens un
peu perdu qu'est-ce que tu aimerais
faire en fait qu'est-ce que tu aimerais
faire aujourd'hui alors clairement en
fait à côté de l'émission et c'est c'est
en même temps c'est normal on était en
stage je pouvais pas trop montrer mais
je compose beaucoup de rêve voilà en
fait c'est ça serait qu'un jour les gens
puissent chanter mes musiques d'accord
quand on compose ça voilà clairement ça
c'est mon rêve d'accord et la star c'est
moi je l'ai vraiment pris comme une
expérience que d'accord jamais j'aurais
pu connaître dans ma vie et tout le
monde pas mais ton rêve c'est d'être
chanteuse ça se voit tu as la scène ta
chatte comme moi tout à l'heure le
charisme
et toi c'est quoi ton c'est la scène
aussi c'est la scène c'est pouvoir
véhiculer des messages etc et chanter
pour chanter moi personnellement ça
m'intéresse pas du tout chanté pour dire
les choses et véhiculer des choses comme
ça ça t'intéresserait ça pourquoi pas
franchement j'adore ça donc why not mais
surtout ouais écrire des chansons pour
voir dire les choses etc la question qui
tue la voilà si vous êtes chez vous
devant votre télé j'espère que vous
appréciez ce moment et encore une fois
je le remercie mais je remercie vraiment
vraiment Jean-Louis bloo fait les gens
de aussi de donne des modes vraiment
en plus parfois on tache là l'émission
et très gentiment ils ont dit oui et
Lionel San qui s'est donné beaucoup de
mal cette semaine pour qu'on pour qu'on
vous ait aujourd'hui parce que peu de
champ facile d'une chaîne à l'autre donc
vraiment je suis très très content et
Mathieu aussi merci beaucoup la question
qui tue faut répondre quoi qu'il arrive
d'accord la personne avec laquelle vous
aviez le moins définitif ça peut arriver
pendant l'aventure c'est qui
n'ayez pas peur
tu as dit qu'elle pleurait tout le temps
clairement il faut savoir déjà qu'au
début de l'aventure je passais mes
soirées à passer par là avec Anisha j'ai
vraiment une chasse et quelqu'un qui m'a
vraiment touché moi quand je pleure
c'est pour de vrai et je pense pour tous
dans cette aventure alors qui qui t'a
saoulé franchement personne m'a saoulé
toi moi par exemple je vous le dis
j'adore Louis mais Louis tu lui dis
Louis tu as faim oh mais non il pleure
tout le temps et parce que c'est comme
ça et que je pense on est tous
différents dans ce programme et si tu as
pas aimé dis-moi non
je suis désolé en fait le moins d'Atom
crochet
je dirais peut-être
louer dans le sens on a moins parlé avec
lui
moi moi je dirais j'ai rien contre elle
ni quoi que ce soit mais encore une fois
c'est parce que on n'a pas vraiment
échangé beaucoup si je dirais pas au là
d'accord et toi c'est avec qui j'ai
commencé donc je pourrais pas dire Paola
mais avec qui j'ai fait le moins de
blagues d'accord et j'ai une autre
question à vous poser on est d'accord
pas de problème la vie est belle quand
ça vote à la fin toi là tu es à côté de
la Seine les gens votent et puis on sait
comment ça marche hein tu sais que je
t'adore quand ça commence par ton nom
c'est pour toi tu sais que je t'adore
c'est un génie tu es le meilleur mais ce
soir c'était Enzo quand ça commence par
toi c'est mort franchement vous en
voulez pas c'est autant que tu étais
mignon on en veut forcément un peu un
pote non d'abord je vous jure que il y
avait tellement pas de problème personne
se tirer dans les pattes dans ce cas
c'était juste on en avait parlé on se
parlait beaucoup de manière objective
dans nos raisons et tout machin et que
nous on a vu notre discussion que
clairement Carla et Paola elle est sur
des produits à la banque vous avez dit
qu'il avait manqué il y avait beaucoup
de gens dans le truc qui m'avaient dit
moi j'étais vraiment je risque de voter
pour cette année vraiment on pleure et
c'est des gens que j'adore juste c'est
comme ça c'est le jeu parce que si vous
étiez malin est-ce qu'il faut faire
c'est voter pour le meilleur pour que le
meilleur se casse puisque c'est une
compétition
stratégiquement
bien sûr Florian mais juste une école de
gars une petite question un peu moins
bienveillante on parlait de ta copine
tout à l'heure et du téléphone etc à un
moment donné elle t'a dit que tu
paraissait trop hautain et que c'était
pas bon du tout et hier il y a public
qui a fait un article disant que les
élèves avaient peut-être le melon que ça
se ressentait notamment dans les
commentaires sur Twitter etc est-ce que
vous trouvez qu'à l'intérieur de la
promo de ces académie là il y a quand
même un petit peu de il y a quand même
quelques boulards qui traînent à parler
comme autour de cette table
en réalité elle a vraiment ce truc de
elle
à l'intérieur on comprend pas l'humour
forcément des élèves léa est très gentil
c'est juste que elle a ce personnage
humoristique de dire je suis ici et
peut-être que ça vous écoute
Mathieu il faut aussi quand même
féliciter la production qui cette année
justement non mais laissez-moi finir
laisse-moi
l'exprimer
non mais vraiment il faut féliciter la
production qui justement était attendu
au tournant ils ont pris le son non
seulement de prendre des gens talentueux
des gens bien élevés visiblement des
gens avec un peu d'éducation d'élocution
de bon sens le casting est parfait
on nous attend au tournant si ça finit
comme dans les Anges et compagnie
attends des conneries il voulait pas ça
bravo pour le casting
est-ce qu'il y a un duo vous auriez aimé
faire avec un artiste
[Musique]
moi j'aurais ah Lewis Capaldi Lewis
Capaldi
[Musique]
Lewis aussi
il s'est passé cette semaine je sais pas
si vous avez vu il y a eu un petit buzz
un peu négatif à propos de leur ballon
qui a débriefé avec Julien parce que
voilà c'est pas très bien passé et elle
a dû s'excuser j'aimerais avoir votre
avis dessus regardez ce qui s'est passé
et si ça gonfle de vivre des émotions
qui sont plus profondes que toi on est
dans la merde
non mais c'est pas ça mais c'est juste
que en fait le truc c'est que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez vraiment du
mal à comprendre que le public met
vraiment beaucoup c'est que
oui parce que si tu respectais le public
tu le draguerais pas en caméra
j'étais perdu ils m'ont juste aider à
voir le sourire en fait sur scène oui
bah c'est des sourires gratuits parce
que moi quand je vois Stan faire sa
prestation il sourit je peux dire qu'il
est avec les gens et il donne toi tu
souris pour draguer non ben non je suis
désolé
je suis pas la seule ça a beaucoup on a
envie de voir ça quand même un peu
d'argent
mais que ça aujourd'hui vous rendez
compte que ça il y a 10 ans dans la Star
Ac c'était un buzz rigolo aujourd'hui on
peut plus rien ça ça fait un clash lors
est-ce que c'est pas grotesque alors que
c'est la prof alors que c'est la preuve
à mon avis elles étaient 150 elle les a
faites j'avais l'impression qu'elles
étaient un conseil qu'elle donne pour
qu'il soit meilleur c'est très bizarre
non mais ça a été quand même assez
violent
tous les profs qui mériteraient d'être
connard avait dû s'excuser que il sera
encore en train de le faire aujourd'hui
hein
dans cette séquence c'est que si vous
regardez tout comme moi parce que vous
avez payé 2,99
vous saurez qu'en fait elle a été plutôt
douce avec tout le monde et c'est juste
Julien qui en a pris plein la trouille
c'est là où on peut quand même je suis
désolé moi quand j'ai vu cette séquence
ça m'a fait penser à du défavoritisme
concernant Julien parce que ce qu'elle
dit le fond je trouve que c'est un peu
du n'importe quoi c'est-à-dire qu'à quel
moment on s'en fout que le public il
t'aime bah c'est le public qui va
acheter
à quel moment tu souris tu dragues le
public bah oui quand tu fais la télé tu
dragues le public
parce que je te jure que là-dessus il y
en a pas du tout du tout on peut tout
reprocher un démon cette année mais pas
de favoritisme il y a rien rien mais
vraiment je te promets là-dessus
t'inquiète pas j'ai les infos de partout
là là j'ai 6 oreillettes
je te promets qu'il y a vraiment rien en
revanche est-ce que ça vous ça vous
touche ou pas de voir qu'un mec comme
Julien qui est un peu à quand même un
foot quand il fait du sport il fait sur
une main il est tout le temps de sauvé
par le public et quelque part des gens
comme vous qui bossaient le public a pas
voté pour vous est-ce que le public
est-ce que ça vous a pas un peu agacé ou
touché moi franchement personnellement
non pas du tout parce que en fait Julien
c'est il a le profil enfin pour moi je
trouve qu'il a un profil hyper attachant
c'est un chanteur non mais oui mais
le chanteur et en plus de ça il
est enfin il a il a il a le profil hyper
attachant en fait et c'est vraiment
compliqué
meilleur chanteur ils font gagner le
meilleur profil ouais à chaque fois moi
j'ai que par exemple j'ai fait Secret
Story j'ai trouvé aucun secret j'ai
jamais joué et j'ai gagné c'est vrai
malheureusement il y en a qui sont très
talentueux mais c'est pas comme ça qui
bien sûr ça reste du chaud de la télé
là que de ce soir
évidemment moi j'aime beaucoup faire la
j'aime beaucoup Paola j'aime enfin
j'aime tout le monde mais moi pour moi
je dirais que ce sera Léa et Shanna qui
sort qui retourneront dans la chambre
elles ont beaucoup progressé elle pense
que Léa sort ce soir en fait Paola
j'aimerais tellement qu'elle reste parce
que c'est avec elle que j'ai commencé
mais le public soit il va voir le
tableau de danse c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'artistique et tout soit il va
voir la progression de Léa et Tiana qui
est vrai
exactement les mêmes trucs donc je pense
que en vrai ça arrive peut-être
et si c'est la danse parce que Carla est
Paola ont un très beau tableau si elles
arrivent à l'assumer
personnalité
en tout cas je voulais vous dire que on
va vous revoir vous revenez quand vous
voulez on va refaire des débriefs je
vous adore tous les trois j'étais
tellement heureux de vous voir pardon le
public aussi merci à tous merci Natacha
à la semaine